[Music]
from the guy who wrote toy story 2 and
in an empty crypto show so i guess it
evens out plus two literal names comes a
show based on the game that taught your
13 year old cousin all their favorite
slurs
arcane league of legends
experience a surprising hit as in it was
a surprise this wasn't crap with a story
that goes deeper than punch the other
team's crystal until it explodes and an
animation style that imagines what if
dreamworks still cared in a show that
mixes cyberpunk steampunk
punk and punky brewster to explore the
eternal struggle between tops and
bottoms and prove that in any conflict
between the elite ruling class and the
masses who live in fear and squalor
there are very fine people on both sides
enter a world where everyone is covered
in buckles and me grown-up bratz dolls
by and jinx one is an ex-con turned narc
who reloads her fists like henry cavill
the other is a manic pixie dream goth
who bites her lip like lin-manuel
miranda it's so cute
[Music]
they may be on opposite sides of a
techno magic war but they're both way
too cute to be anything but the heroes i
mean right in a show that goes all in on
the everyone good as hot while everyone
bat is physically deformed trope watch
good evil
hot but when armed so evil super evil
good also oh
while these madcap vai jings go down in
the undercity take the elevator up to
piltover for supply chain issues the
series the hex gates must remain open
piltover status as a global shipping
lane depends on it without the hex gates
my goats cannot reach foreign markets
till winter in this walled paradise
where magic is like science and science
is like crossfit
as you trace the rise and fall of jayce
a himbo who invents new ways to make the
poor's work faster the atlas gauntlets
the mining colonies and the fishers can
work faster and without fatigue they'll
get seduced by power and maybe his
friend victor too or partners no no not
in front of all of them because this
show loves it when guys and gals go
right up to the edge of being more than
pals but nothing more you're hot cupcake
can jeopardize that china release either
that or french animators make everything
look sexual probably both
so dive in to a sprawling new adventure
that's so much better than how it sounds
on paper mixing tons of easter eggs for
game fans with fully fleshed out
characters and themes they've got plenty
while we're down here scraping together
coins mixing prequel level plot lines
exactly the sort of thing we wanted to
fix with hex tech not just
trade disputes with anime style action
that might as well have them yelling at
their attack names
and somehow mixing imagine dragons with
music you'd actually listen to
no no that this this gym has to be a
fluke don't push your luck stupid good
video game show
starring
sister from another resistor
oh mr s you're my pudding thor loser
elizabeth from bioshock infinite world's
okay is dad professor cuddles md
mommy issues a genius with a cough oh
he's screwed dexter's lab if you do not
smoke this we have a problem the tva's
number one ranked player
little buff boys
do or do not are going to cost you extra
that will and oh are they okay
[Music]
very unclear how species works in
piltover seems like it's 99.99 human and
then every once in a while there's like
one hamster must be really hard to date
the first rule of fight club is we don't
talk about bruno
find the halo
win the war
who patrols the paw patrol
please oil the door it keeps going